[Music]
you know we worked in the same network
for a long time and uh always uh as
always very appreciative of your
professionalism and and and it always
seemed to me that you got started in
this business at a very young age you
were you were broadcasting when you were
like three years old yeah i believe
and i'm curious what was there ever a
tough job you had before broadcasting or
did you get right in and start
broadcasting and then the rest was gravy
in truth broadcasting is the only real
job i've ever had but i did have a
summer job uh between semesters at
syracuse university when i was about 19
20 years old
selling encyclopedias door to door now
you were encyclopedia i was an
encyclopedia salesman a bad one because
i couldn't handle the rejection and the
whole
concept is rejection because you got to
knock on 100 doors and maybe one or two
will invite you in you know and this is
in the 70s when it was kind of a mark of
prestige for baby boomer parents to have
the encyclopedia britannica or whatever
in the bookcase it's all been rendered
completely moot now well it's funny
because there are young people watching
right now who don't know what we're
talking about right
they're here right now but it's
absolutely it used to be before the
internet every family if you were lucky
you had an encyclopedia and any school
project you would go to it and look up
annual rainfall or whatever exactly
right and so i would knock on the door
and the person would answer the door
usually the gentleman of the household
and i'd say and they had a kind of a
script that you'd say hi
working in the area talking to everybody
do you have a moment and invariably the
guy would say
i don't have a moment and as he was
slamming the door he'd say i'm not
interested right and then you were
instructed to say
i see
not interested in the nation's future
not interested in your children's
education i'll mark that down
and then hopefully that would make the
guy one time in a hundred feel guilty
enough no it would make him hit you in
the adam's apple as hard as he could it
would come not interested in your
child's future
right
we call this the appro we call this
approach the dick yeah
yeah it did it did not work well in the
entire summer i sold one set right of of
collier's encyclopedias you bought those
didn't you
my mother did
so you could prop the doors open so they
couldn't slam it on you wow
uh all right well you've had uh a lot of
uh
fantastic moments in your broadcasting
career one was very recent where you're
interviewing
uh webb simpson yeah he won the u.s open
won the u.s open you have this uh
interview with webb simpson and then
madness breaks out do you want to
preface this or should we say this this
guy is now apparently showing up in
other places because he showed up a
couple weeks ago at the navy notre dame
football game which was played in london
so we're wondering where he's going to
strike next but this is where he struck
first there it is
you go 68-68
on the weekend and a burst of three
straight birdies and four and a five
hole stretch turned around for you today
yeah that was kind of the difference i
got off to a slow start but i knew that
i i knew always something to spice
matters up
yeah enjoy the jail cell pal
you know what i love
it was
beautifully shot
it is
it's almost like it's shot like a comedy
piece right the way he comes right into
fame at the perfect time at the perfect
angle
and you don't you don't see him right
now because he's not in my you know line
of vision because i'm looking right at
simpson and i could hear the sound in
the first split second
but it doesn't look like kelsey grammer
does it looks like kelsey graham
looks like he's
he just had some bad cheese popcorn
and so i didn't realize
exactly what was going on i heard it but
i thought it was further off in the
distance and then the guy comes and
yanks him away and what you don't say
literally he threw him into a green side
sand trap oh that's great the guy is now
in the in the sand trap is he still like